[Música]
numa altura em que renato debate sobre
energia nuclear em portugal comemora os
30 anos da luta do povo dos hell em
peniche contra a instalação de uma
central na localidade assim que foi
aliás conhecer alguns dos participantes
desta marcha de 15 de março de 76
[Música]
um dia um dia bom dia mulher todos já lá
vão
já lá vão 40 mais 42 anos
temos de falar daqui mais à frente sobre
sobre o filme sobre o sino da igreja de
nossa senhora na casa da nossa senhora
da guia a em fraude
eu escolhi o tema da energia cidadania e
democracia que o cabo é a mensagem que
eu pretendo é que transmitir é é uma
mensagem que de alguma forma vai muito
do que o que foi esta grande
a primeira grande manifestação popular
que foi corajosa por parte da população
da da população de israel é e ao mesmo
tempo também dar conta de como é que o
carro um jovem na altura tinha 21 anos e
como é que essa é o meu envolvimento
nesta iniciativa foi importante para
coisas com as futuras
a idéia desta comunicação é também fazer
esta ligação entre a energia que cada um
de nós tem o dever da cidadania num
quadro democrático e como é que também a
mensagem competição nós estava no chão e
21 anos tinha 25 de abril tinha ocorrido
dar o time pouco pouco tempo é e como
marfim com muitos nós nessa nessa altura
estávamos envolvidos em múltiplas
iniciativas já era trabalhadora
à época mas participava né não as
comissões de moradores no caso concreto
da comissão moradores do lugar da
estrada e tinha um corpo constituímos
que empreendemos agora fala se muito em
empreendedorismo num trilho que era o
trio que é desenvolver e abrir 11 jornal
que ela chamava o orago eu quis mesmo
francisco
dentro desse trabalho
afinal a falar em 1975 entre a altura
começa ouvir falar sobre a questão da
daquilo que dá vou fazer nos treinos na
zona do monte velho aí aí é franca
sobre uma hipotética construção duma de
uma central nuclear
o volos é é evoluir para obter muita
informação está disponível a a à época
eu lembro da daquilo que foram tradições
que fazia do francis muita considerada
por pela fonte cautela um grande rolo
está com o celular o momento pouco tempo
realista do século e que é era
responsável por um movimento ecológico
português é por phelps salvas a falar do
que cantava o que estava a acontecer lá
pela para os treinos do domínio velho
procurar informação e por aquilo que nós
fizemos foi também entrarmos neste
debate que se ia fazendo já há aqui pelo
pelo conselho
é assim que é bom tanto é que surge este
final da qual era diretor mas é
fundamentalmente uma equipa e que
fizemos foi transferida do dia 3/12 e
adaptar
aquilo que nós devíamos vento
fundamentalmente
a bibliografia que nos era que 10 é
disponibilizado esta sam é é excecional
que curiosamente tem a ingrata de 12 de
março de 1976 quando a manifestação se
verificou a 15 ex março era tanto texto
o trabalho que nós iríamos tínhamos
fazendo e é quando o trabalho e que come
à época todos também estão recordados
que as comissões de moradores no via sul
da freguesia é fran fazer parte da
freguesia de atouguia da baleia e todos
nós nos recordamos daquilo que os que
mais ativamente tiveram acompanhar os
seus 25 mil
as comissões de moradores eram aquelas
que faziam a ligação entre as
comunidades ea e aí o poder local e por
isso a comissão durou 2 fran teve aqui
um papel importantíssimo na dinamização
também nesta é e se tiver que é envolveu
muita gente é de todo o concelho e
concelhos limítrofes e banho daquilo que
foi o dia 15 de março de 2010 caso
em 1976 uma uma segunda feira faltei ao
emprego eu e os meus colegas é e manhã
fria e é que o que nós
as imagens que nós temos é da chegada ao
ar da nossa senhora da guia de gente
imagina para enfim poder participar
nesta iniciativa é que entra digamos o
ossinho como dizia há pouco
bata do doce anda criar a menina filha
mas nesse caso a mãe dos jovens rafael e
do samuel é traçar ela bate com tal
violência ana concorda no sino que
entrei na altura o aval cair então é boa
há um ano e criar um mini já avançar na
avançada idade ela não tem nada que
aquela imagem de bom não é puro não ver
paulo que coisas deixou de fazer
então pega mesmo no geral e as virtuosas
eu ia dar aquela que ela é aquela imagem
embalagens quisermos de uma de uma
determinação
eu sempre isso porque estávamos lá não
via comunicação social nenhuma porque a
comunicação social não ligou a
comunicação social nacional não ligou a
anunciar na manifestação que iria ver
uma e eu não tenho dúvida foi a primeira
manifestação verdadeiramente popular
genuína é em torno da da defesa do do
ambiente uma causa que todos
eu creio que todos estão aqui nesta sala
também se identificam e precisamos ter
esta edição especial em cima é do do
jornal do seu namorado e que enfim posso
dizer que há umas depois podem consultar
este material irá ficar disponível
ali uma uma frase fortíssima porque nós
fomos eram os do ouro outros disse cleto
outros de motorizada que roça tratores
carro apesar de tudo o que conseguir sua
vida e era ir até lá é chávez são os
ombros portuguesas ombros e quando
chegamos
quando chegamos o homem velho
transportados dessa é dessa forma que o
que foi interessante foi ver
e tem as imagens a earth da onu havia
céu fiz na altura em que houve a rede se
a assinatura não via nada e portanto f e
somos poucos é é única fotografia que
existe essa de transporte nada pelo que
assumir e das suas provas pela pela
proíbe à procura do doce o que um estava
a atenção que não se viu que tinha na
assim certamente é o puto 21 anos e
saber o que a população frango e e fazer
com que o irã entre aspas personal tudo
está bom
gravamos nos postos a obesidade e da
atenas quando estamos ali volta da
antena o primeiro faro e o bloco é
impune como uma esferográfica consumar
uma arma também será a arma que eu tinha
é a registar que o que eram frases de a
uma frase que o frasco que uma companhia
pra toda a vida que é um símbolo também
para mim do réu que é alguém que diz
força força é pra tirar essa merda já
congemi erram ea volta etc
essa frase escrevia para não é fácil
procurar agora né
na altura no mandaqui o turbilhão de
sentimentos
eu estava aterrorizada estava pesado e
portanto transportamos preço
profissional
nesta edição especialíssima era feita
nas instalações da sessão
o estreante dodô técnica época
bom bom e com aquelas a família toda é
bom a missão de moradores
a emtu este comunicado é explicado em um
comunicado pra mim histórico tem essa
carga toda quem acompanhou foi duplicado
temos na nossa empresa entregasse os
primos o torcedor aqui à época também é
e eu fizemos a fotografia também
rotatório a época é certa nada
mas não foi por isso que essa mensagem
não pessoa e portanto novo guia sp e não
via antena 1 não via se que não via
correio da manhã não via nada e portanto
foi a partir desta noite se por um azul
este comunicado e aí é que eu vou ter
alguma dificuldade mas vou tentar ler
aqui alguns dos aspectos eu não quis
tirar nada do do comunicado
mas é a partir deste comunicado que
surge e com um verão que embaixo
constituição é também uma comissão que
terá como finalidade a divulgação da
luta das povoadas promoções e contribuir
para o alargamento deste movimento
antinuclear onde já existem núcleos
nomeadamente nos concelhos de caldas e
ao estado de caldas bombarral bombarral
impunes e com uma determinação era
mandar parar os trabalhos
isso desde logo bom e com onzes bom
caso os trabalhos recomecem população
fahel aos presentes junta andré e todas
as outras vizinhas tomaram as medidas
que considerarem estar em destaque uma
verdadeira ameaça e é parte da equipe
pois vai no dia a seguir à comunicação
social nacional com expresso na altura o
século é e companhia limitada a gente
tem aqui um ponto aqui para o que é que
nesta nesta nesta fase é que o julga que
vale a pena aqui e dizer é que o sol
digamos como como como nata é que a
atitude que a população do réu teve ela
é ajustada é ela existe
é quase como que o prenúncio do
envolvimento populações nas questões da
sustentabilidade ambiental e se
eventualmente a central nuclear de vez
tivesse construída
se calhar não
viemos aqui esses produtos que e o
simbolicamente vou entregar um ataque à
china este surto públicos depois que são
é são ao seu carro é o exemplo é a
qualidade da nossa arte cultura e para
elas se quiserem salvar os pretos por
ela criado da mesma maneira que não
teremos o repolho com a qualidade que
nós temos que olhar também não teremos
está precisando é privada
digamos do nosso do nosso país que por
certo não seria a mesma coisa
é um equipamento nó e se os nossos
reposição foram eternizadas é também a
qualquer coisa que ficou eternizado
a partir desta
todos os dias e em favela pra mim isso
não fazer uma central
o temporal não sai nunca teriam achado
era muito zé
convido os a irem - a procurar ea
figurar em eleição mas esta é
fundamental está eternizado
isso é uma marca importante estão
patrimônio réu é um patrimônio do do do
conselho no início do ano em uma das
matas adicionais 30 anos 30 anos depois
depois que eu quero ao júri o trabalho
do estudante em 1976 era presidente da
câmara municipal com isso as coisas mais
fantásticas que em colaboração com a
junta freguesia franco o silvinho
organizarmos a comemoração dos 30 anos e
importa aqui foi digamos o transportar
para para pra réu para sempre e que o
valor patrimonial e um fato extintivo
franco
transportamos também é parte de israel
desse imaginário ambiental a questão das
energias renováveis lembranças daquela
fotografia aquela banda desenhada ou
indenização
mas é esse lugar mas o vento é e foi no
dia 15 março de 2010 casado 2000 e sair
que assinamos o protocolo com vista à
criação para que é é único no serra da
raiz dos fios à noite diz março
exatamente nesta esta simbologia ligar
as renováveis aqui foi a atitude de ovo
este é o único da falha que foi incluído
neste pacote com a agora é de pedro
novais pro forma é que reabilitasse mas
esta foi uma negociação dos 140 mil
euros para a reabilitação e que este
amigo neste momento pela pela rua você
assim com isso condenamos o seu visto é
que esse é um longe estivermos nas
renováveis
avançamos também e agora sim com está em
dia continua em desenvolvimento com
neste caso é a energia energia das ondas
é este processo é um processo evolutivo
começa alguns também em 2006 e 2007 está
num processo
e curiosamente isaía poucos metros a
poucas centenas de metros do local onde
estava prevista a construção da central
da central nuclear
mas podemos falar também de outra de
outras dimensões
mas haja é como é que essa é aquela
energia pode ser utilizada também para
esta energia e ambiente para a promoção
do território é e ele se aposentou com
esse capital de onde vem todo o trabalho
que se foi desenvolvendo essas
fotografias são do mês de outubro é
passado em uma praia portuguesa é nossa
supertubos e mostra o potencial e forma
como também através das modalidades
sustentáveis nós podemos promover o
nosso território é substituir os trilhos
foram tiradas por mim não a montagem no
art
nada importante essas são se quisermos
também um caminho de futuro
[Música]
junta tudo esta perceção sobre as
questões da sustentabilidade e para
determinar vários transportar vos também
para 11 outra dimensão que a dimensão da
relação entre mês caso não crescia
participativa aquela que através destes
desafios nossa incrementamos para a
democracia representativa e é não a
gostar de alguma uma democracia
participativa que seja consistente se
ela não tiver crescendo crescia
representativa também seus shows e
boates mais do que também andaram só nas
redes sociais é tetra e irmos como a
população sofreu fez jogar nos fechadas
pegar nos carros
irusta coisa concreta e portanto sempre
que houver a deus para que agora site
está em revisão
elaborar um novo plano estratégico que
acha percepção rompeu para que depois
não se diga e bom agora é resolver nas
minhas costas ou isso não é corresponder
aos apelos que vierem a ser infantil que
possamos fazer os cenários e os
funcionários foram traçados
o chão agora provavelmente atualizados
em função daquilo que nós pensamos pra
ser o melhor mas nunca nunca
nós fazemos o papel tem enfrenta
nunca nunca ficaram só como um um leão
mas também não ser uns esse neoliberais
que levantou na broa como rival vasco
essa linha viva é o cenário e eu acho
que aquilo que vai ao encontro daquilo
que o nosso é um tipo isso eu crescia
participativa democracia representativa
uma não pode viver sem outra serão
incompleta é um pouco e se lá esse papel
que eu é que faço não sem antes de dizer
que nós temos um futuro na à nossa
frente e este exemplo do frango por
vencer
o elemento foi o argumento que sentia e
recebi convite para nos darmos também
mais energia que com nossa cidadania
iremos reforçar a democracia
[Aplausos]
[Música]